Vadim and I have been using and testing
the iPhone 14s for close to two weeks
now and although the 14 pro Max is by
far my favorite iPhone and I highly
recommend it to anybody wanting to
upgrade there are still some software
and Hardware limitations that you should
be aware of before buying so I'm going
to be discussing those in this video as
well as some solutions to some of the
problems so let's get right into it the
first one is battery life the last few
years iPhones have been amazing with
battery life but unfortunately this year
it is different now I ignored the
battery life the first few days since I
was using it so much but I was shocked
on my first normal use date when my 14
pro Max was at 18 battery before 4 30 PM
I hope that it would get better the
following week but nope and even
Angelica commented that this past
weekend she was having a top off for 14
pro each day before the day was over now
this is because of a few new features
that are nice but kill the battery and
thankfully there are a few adjustments
that can be made to help which I'll
share after the next few problems the
second is the display brightness now I
love that it gets super bright outdoors
and that's very helpful but as I was
shooting videos from my insanely
detailed camera comparison between the
14 the 13 and 12 Pro Max by the way make
sure you guys are subscribed so you guys
don't miss that I noticed that the 14
series consistently chooses a higher
auto brightness than the rest of the
older phones and in my regular use I
kept having to manually turn it down in
the evenings this might be because Apple
added a second ambient light sensor
which is now in the back and it's
helpful since it will bump up the
brightness if you have the Sun or
something else that is bright behind it
whereas the 13s and older wouldn't but I
would still love to have an auto
brightness preference adjustment in the
settings third is the always-on display
which I also love and I talked about how
much better it was than Samsung's but I
keep finding it too bright in many
scenarios making it look like the phone
is on now the phone does automatically
adjust the brightness of the always on
display but just like the regular screen
brightness it biases too bright and and
of course all of these are leading to
worse battery life so here are some work
rounds while we still don't have a way
to adjust the auto brightness one thing
you could do is to use manual brightness
for the times that you don't need the
super crazy 2000 nits that really drains
your battery so the manual won't allow
that the only thing is that unlike
Android it has a pain to find a setting
on an iPhone but what I did was use
shortcuts to create a link workaround
and I placed that shortcut on my home
page that automatically opens the
settings so I can quickly adjust that
for the always-on display instead of
just turning it off like some have I
created a custom Focus mode where
nothing is changed other than dimming
the lock screen super dark while still
showing off my nice wallpaper when I
raise it this will save battery life
while still showing widgets and
notifications and if you want to take
this further I change the text and the
icons colors to Red which is the color
that has the lowest power usage for OLED
displays and it still pops with the
screen dimming mode if you want to go
even further set your lock screen to a
full black image so maybe Samsung was
right with their always on since we're
talking about battery life we should
cover Chargers now everybody knows Apple
no longer gives you a charger in the box
but that is not the problem what is is
the fact that they recommend their own
20 watt Apple charging brick even though
the new 14 pro accepts up to 28 watts of
charging and runs at 25 and 26 and the
max runs at 27 peaking at 29. so if
you're gonna buy one make sure to buy a
30 watt model so we'll charge faster and
be more future proof even on regular
iPhones thankfully bass has partnered up
with us to show off their new 30 watt
super PSI Pro quick Chargers which
support full speed PD fast charging with
enhanced temperature control but they
also come with an additional USB type a
port for broad compatibility as well as
foldable prongs that make it much more
compact than Apple's version not only
that but they've also got their Adam
into 10 000 milliamp hour Palm size
power bank which literally has three
times the battery capacity of the iPhone
114 Pro and also supports full speed PD
30 watt fast charging just like the
Super Side Pro on top of that it comes
with a high quality metal casing for
durability as well as a convenient
display to check how much battery has
left and it gets two extra USB type A
ports so you can charge three devices at
once and the power bank itself has fast
charging capability as well and can be
fully charged in 2 hours and 45 minutes
so go ahead and check out this basis
charger and the power bank by using
links in the video description below the
next one is screen dimming we talked
about this a lot with the iPhone 12 pros
and pro Max's the 13s and with the 14s
it has gotten a lot better but what I
have found is that the iPhone 14 pro
actually dims more so than the 14 pro
Max and that makes sense because it's a
smaller body so the heat has less area
to expand to and that is just a little
bit annoying because it's still there so
if you don't want to deal with screen
dimming if you want the ultimate
brightness outside if you're gonna do
stuff like drones I would suggest go for
the 14 pro Max the next one is esim now
I've mentioned this before how it sucks
that Apple did this in some countries
and that even though it was easy to
switch over to esim I still had some
issues with some calls not coming
through I had some weird pop-ups and
then the last couple days my wife is
trying to send me texts and images and
it just wasn't coming through I wish
that Apple stuck with the SIM models
everywhere because there's just an empty
space where the Sim used to be in these
phones and I know some people straight
up didn't buy a new iPhone 14 because
their carrier did not support it so they
bought a 13 series phone instead and now
I want to switch over to the cameras
because we do have some issues and I
also have some workarounds with you now
the first I want to talk about is video
this phone is amazing at shooting video
has the new action mode The Cinematic
mode is a lot better but what Apple did
not give us is 8k video now when we had
the league weeks of a 48 megapixel
camera coming to the iPhone 14 pro and
pro Max we thought that was because of
8K video that is because this sensor is
perfect for shooting 8K video without
having a big crop like you get with the
Samsung phones but unfortunately Apple
didn't give it to us and I think that
this is just an excuse to add it next
year while giving you a good reason to
upgrade now if you don't believe the
apple is just holding this back think of
last year with the iPhone 13 Series
where cinematic mode could only shoot
1080p without hdrs limited to 30 FPS we
thought that this was a hardware
limitation but now with the iPhone 14
this thing does the 4K HDR cinematic
mode even though it uses the same camera
as the 13 Pro and the same processor so
it is not a harder limitation but a
software and even though it came out now
with the same Hardware apple is not
adding it as a software update to the 13
Pro phone so that is just them getting
you to upgrade now I know some people
say why do you even need 8K video well
you can say the same thing with 4K or
even 1080p before that personally if the
hardware is capable I would rather have
the best resolution possible so that 5
years 10 years from now when I have uh
footage of my kids places we go I have
the best quality possible and now let's
switch over to photos Apple's really
hyping up the 48 megapixel sensor all
the detail that you'll get from it but
the problem is if you're just taking
regular photos and they're using their
quad Bayer technology the photos don't
look any more detailed than the iPhone
13 Pro photos at least in most lighting
conditions that's because apple is
compressing all of those to 12
megapixels and they're recording in heic
and the detail just isn't there now when
we switch over to Apple 48 megapixel Pro
raw it looks so much better in every
single way but the problem is that the
file sizes go from around two to three
megabytes to around 75 they are massive
and apple doesn't give us an option to
make small files that are compressed not
raw like Samsung does and even worse is
that there is no easy way to convert
these huge files into compressed ones
that are going to be roughly three four
times larger than the 12 megapixel ones
online Apple says that's going to take
up a lot of storage so you'll probably
want to upgrade your phone to more
storage or their option is to save to
iCloud and then download and then it's
going to eat up your iCloud space and
your data and of course they have a link
just to bring you to getting iCloud or
upgrading your storage now I searched
everywhere how to do this and the
easiest way if you can believe it is to
edit the photo first then upload to your
files app let it upload to the cloud and
then you take that re-download it send
it to photos that will convert it and
that'll make the file size roughly
around 16 or so megabytes instead of
being 75. thankfully the quality of that
file is very similar to the raw file a
little bit more compression a little bit
sharper but that just saves so much
space now if you don't like doing this
method and having to find the photo
delete the old one you can actually
download the Highlight app which is a
paid app and that will allow you to take
photos right away in that converted
format it's about 15 megabytes it's HAC
so it's higher quality and it looks
slightly better than the converted files
themselves and even slightly sharper
than Apple's Pro raw file now know this
video is not sponsored by halide but I
just thought it was really cool that
you're able to do that and with that
they even have options to add widgets to
your lock screen so you can quick open
that app for those images when you want
that detail or even jump into the ultra
wide the regular the telephoto mode so
it's definitely a cool app but you do
have to pay for it now the next one is
kind of tied into this and that is the
fact that the lightning Port is still
here and even worse it is still USB 2.0
which is insanely slow the old Samsung
S8 plus was USB 3.1 and when I was
transferring these huge Pro raw files to
offload them I was getting around 20 25
megabytes per second transfer speeds
instead of what could be about 400 450
and we have shown you guys that the
storage that is in here is insanely fast
even faster than the fast ones last year
so it's more than capable but apple is
just limiting it probably because they
want to bring USB type-c next year or
even Thunderbolts and make it a much
bigger deal and lastly I have this very
simple one but I keep running into this
issue and that's the fact that the Erp
speaker no longer has a grill right
there at the glass and because of that
stuff keeps jamming into there and it's
a pain to clean out because the slit is
very small so what I found as a solution
is to have a can of air and that's the
easiest way to blow all that stuff lint
whatever out of there and to keep it
clean and of course sounding its best so
there you guys go those are my top 10
problems with this phone after using it
for close to two weeks hopefully all the
solutions that I gave you guys helped
you guys out click above to subscribe
there if you guys want to see my
ultimate camera comparison with the past
two generations and then this new one
check out that video right over there
that's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]